so during my interview on yesterday's
show with
coleman hughes this topic of fixing
policing came up and we talked about a
couple of different ideas related to
that and one of the things that i had
mentioned was focusing in a little bit
on traffic enforcement as a sort of
proxy to fighting
a lot of what's wrong with policing in
the united states and i got a bunch of
emails about it from people saying
how would that what would that look like
can you talk about that a little more
so let's let's do that today now as a
pretext to this
i don't have any misconception that
dealing with
traffic laws is the solution to every
problem with policing in the united
states it's not
dealing with traffic enforcement
wouldn't do anything about lack of
training or improper training or the
wrong training
it wouldn't address qualified immunity
if that's something we want to look at
it wouldn't
you know deal with funding or a whole
bunch of other things but there's a
reason why
traffic enforcement is arguably some of
the lowest hanging fruit that we should
look at right away when it comes to
policing which is that
traffic enforcement is number one an
area where police are allowed
a lot of discretion and inherent bias
manifests when there is discretion and
number two traffic enforcement and
traffic related
uh infractions are the primary way in
which
americans interact with police by number
of incidents every single year and so
what what i mean by this is
when it comes to traffic enforcement
we're all familiar with situations
in which i get pulled over and you get
pulled over
and are told we were driving 12 miles an
hour over the speed limit in other words
the pretext for the stop is exactly the
same
but there might be very different
outcomes based on the discretion of the
officer so
i might end up with a speeding ticket
and points on my
insurance paying a higher insurance rate
for several years
i might get my car searched because the
officer
believes that they smell alcohol in my
car when they pull me over
meanwhile you might get pulled over
doing the same
alleged 12 miles an hour over the speed
limit and you get a verbal warning and
have a nice day and the repercussions of
the discretion that is applied
by officers to the same scenario
can be dramatically different even when
the facts are essentially just
the same and this could be just a result
of the bias of the police officer
officers have a lot of discretion in
terms of who they pull over
when they see somebody run a stop sign
for example
once they pull them over who do they
question more aggressively
whose vehicles are they more interested
in searching
who do they have step out of the vehicle
for a field sobriety test when a car
drives by with a tail light out
that discretion can be the difference
between an interaction that leads to a
police shooting
or ultimately an arrest versus someone
who just
drives home not even realizing that they
drove by a police officer with their
taillight
taillight out so because traffic
enforcement is the most common way that
people come into contact with police
every year year in and year out
and it can serve as a sort of blank
slate from which investigations can
start
we should be looking at this very
closely so what are some ways
to reduce the discretion which can be
influenced by bias
when it comes to traffic enforcement one
idea
is to replace some traffic enforcement
with
automation whenever possible by that we
we mostly mean
cameras because of course that is a way
to eliminate
a bias from an individual officer now
you can still choose to put the cameras
in certain neighborhoods and not in
others
and you may have people who are of a
certain economic class
who can better lobby to prevent the
cameras from coming into their
neighborhoods and push the cameras
into poor neighborhoods or black
neighborhoods or whatever the case may
be
but it's something to look at you can
have situations you know on highways
it's typical that on highways people
everybody's driving over the speed limit
then you need to figure out if you're
going to replace highway
speed traps with cameras well how much
speeding is acceptable there are some
complexities there but at least in some
cases
automating elements of traffic
enforcement
would dramatically reduce interactions
with police and it would therefore
reduce the number of interactions that
become
problematic replacing traffic
enforcement
and speed traps with police cameras
would limit
the bias of an officer in leading to
discretion being used in a
discriminatory way
for example now it's not a replacement
for fixing all of the other things that
are broken certainly
but it would be significant nonetheless
so then there's the idea
of having someone other than armed
police
handle some traffic enforcement we've
talked about
homelessness mental illness do we really
need armed police handling
calls to 9-1-1 related to homelessness
it's probably better suited to some
other kind of professional
if we can't have better trained officers
trained like social
workers for example maybe
there would be some other type of
professional that would be better
suited here something analogous could be
you know
for certain types of traffic infractions
you would have something other than an
armed police officer now the devil is in
the details of course
and it's true that while the vast
majority of traffic infractions
don't escalate in any way and the ones
that do sometimes escalate because of
the officer
there can be traffic infractions where
someone knows that they have a warrant
and it can lead to erratic behavior
there's a lot of guns floating around
there so
you've got you've got to think it
through right there's this is not an
obvious and easy
solution but it's something to to look
at but the point is and this is why i
feel strongly about it
when 20 million motorists per year
are pulled over according to the
stanford policing project and these
interactions traffic related
interactions
open the door to such a huge amount of
discretion on the part of the officer
it's an area of low-hanging fruit where
finding some aspects to automate
finding other areas better suited for a
different type of professional than an
armed police officer
we could make a lot of progress there
while i don't want to
ignore this while we look at dealing
with
training qualified immunity lack of a
bad actors database at the federal level
all of the different things that we've
been talking about
let me know your thoughts does this seem
like an avenue that should be pursued
what do you see as the obstacles what do
you see as the possible
shortcomings of it that maybe i'm
ignoring let me know what you think